the Boy Scouts of America will start
admitting girls as Cub Scouts next year
a program for older girls is expected to
begin by 2019 it will allow them to earn
the coveted rank of Eagle Scout the Boy
Scouts sister organization that's the
Girl Scouts of the USA criticized this
decision Jim Axelrod is here with what
led to the change after years of debate
a lot of people have questions about
this Jim good morning good morning
Wednesday's announcement marks the most
significant change in the history of the
organization one that was founded more
than a century ago to teach boys about
loyalty bravery and kindness for more
than 107 years the Boy Scouts of America
helped define for many what being a boy
is all about but in a unanimous decision
the Boy Scouts of America announced it
would welcome girls into its iconic Cub
Scout program and will create a path for
older girls to earn the highest rank of
Eagle Scout Mike sir Baugh is the chief
Scout executive what we found is that
parents have less available time today
they're looking for more options and
they want to involve the whole family
for a 16 year old Sidney Ireland this
means she can officially join her
brothers New York city-based troop next
year it also means she'll be eligible to
earn the rank of Eagle Scout a position
held by former President Gerald Ford
astronaut Neil Armstrong and director
Steven Spielberg I can now officially be
awarded merit badges that I have
achieved and brings that I have gone to
but the news was not celebrated by the
Boy Scouts counterpart in a statement
Girl Scouts of the USA stood by its
current policy saying we believe
strongly in the importance of an all
girl girl lead and girl friendly
environment with a program tailored
specifically to their unique
developmental needs for girls like
Ireland being allowed into the Boy
Scouts means her needs are finally being
met not every girl has to want to do the
things that the Girl Scouts do I want to
do the things that the Boy Scouts do in
the past two and a half years the Boy
Scouts also announced it would allow
gay leaders and transgender Scouts and
while critics say these moves are simply
a reaction to diminishing membership
numbers Scout leaders say it's all about
fairness
watch out thank you so much we disagree
without notes are good okay no I agree
girls can do anything I just like Boy
Scouts and Girl Scouts